afghanistan falls to the taliban in the
worst foreign policy debacle for the
united states since america's withdrawal
from vietnam i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from bigtech with the
vpni trust visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment it is a very bad day in the
news we'll get to that in a second first
let us talk about a simple fact you're
spending too much money on your cell
phone bill take a look at it right now
if you're with verizon or at t or
t-mobile you are simply paying too much
it's time to switch over to puretalk
puretalk can save your family over 800 a
year they've got the same great coverage
as all of those big providers because
puretalk is on the exact same network as
one of the big three but at a fraction
of the price and switching is as easy as
switching out your sim card you can keep
your phone keep your number or get huge
discounts on the latest iphones and
androids plus right now you can get a
limited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month and if you go
over on data they're not going to charge
you for it there's a reason pure talk is
the highest rated wireless company by
consumer affairs why they are the
preferred wireless partner of amac from
your cell phone dial pound 250 and say
my name ben shapiro save an additional
50 on your very first month that is
pound two five zero say my name ben
shapiro to save a bundle on your cell
phone coverage again you're gonna get
the same exact grade coverage as one of
the big providers except at a fraction
of the price go check them out right now
is i'll pound 250 say my name ben
shapiro to save an additional 50 off
your very first month of coverage of
pure talk usa alrighty well obviously
the big news of the day and of the year
and frankly of the last 20 years is the
taliban is now in charge of afghanistan
again because joe biden decided it would
be a wonderful wonderful idea to simply
leave with no plan
with no actual transition with no
support for the people who are still
there and so what we have on our hands
is a full-scale disaster area now
remember it was just one month ago that
joe biden was saying that don't worry
it's not going to be like saigon it's
not going to be like the united states
leaving vietnam with helicopters taking
off from roofs and the viet cong simply
rushing in and killing everybody they
don't like it's not going to be anything
like that it'll be orderly after all
there's a big afghan army and we've been
arming them and supporting them here was
joe biden saying what is now in
retrospect the dumbest thing he possibly
could have said one month ago
do you see any parallels between this
withdrawal and what happened in vietnam
with some people feeling whatsoever
zero what you had is you had entire
brigades breaking through the gates of
our embassy
six if i'm not mistaken
the taliban is not the south of the
north vietnamese army
they're not they're not remotely
comparable in terms of capability
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof of a
embassy in the of the united states from
afghanistan it is not at all comfortable
this dungeon-headed fool this
unbelievable
coward all of that was a lie that was a
lie and it was perfectly obvious it was
a lie at the time here's the thing
they're still lying in real time the
secretary of state anthony blinken he
was asked on sunday
whether this was like saigon and here is
what he had to say
president biden said that under no
circumstance and that was his word those
were his words under no circumstance
where the u.s
personnel embassy personnel be airlifted
out of uh kabul in a replay of the
scenes that we saw in saigon in 1975
so
isn't that exactly what we're seeing now
i mean even the images are evocative of
what happened in vietnam
let's take a step back this is
manifestly not saigon the fact of the
matter is this
we went to afghanistan 20 years ago uh
with one mission in mind and that was
the deal with the people who attacked us
on 9 11.
and that mission has been successful
okay this is insane it's exactly like
chicago by the way it's not like saigon
let me just show you a picture of saigon
and a picture of what happened the other
day just side by side okay so on your
left hand side you'll see saigon you
have people attempting to escape
attempting to climb on to u.s
helicopters to get out of the way before
the vietcong russian and killed
everybody and on the right that is an
american ferry helicopter that is taking
off from the top of the united states
embassy trying to evacuate people from
the topic
nothing like it nothing you see no
resemblances none
weird because they look really exactly
the same like exactly the same
and by the way you have the taliban
taking full control of the presidential
palace in kabul and scenes reminiscent
of vietnam circa 1975. here is some of
that footage
what you are looking at right now
is taliban fighters
inside the presidential palace taliban
fighters placing their guns on the desks
sitting behind the desk
of we assume that is the uh desk of the
the afghan president a fairly
stunning turnarounds of events
in kabul okay remember last week last
week the biden administration said it
would be somewhere between 30 and 90
days before the taliban even had the
capacity to take over kabul it took
about 30 to 90 hours for them to
actually do it 30 to 90 hours cnn's
kylie atwood now reporting the american
flag at the u.s embassy in kabul has
been taken down she says this marks a
final step in the evacuation of the
embassy kylie says the withdrawal of
embassy personnel is happening quote
incredibly rapidly today and the process
is now expected to conclude by this
evening she says uh minus the small
number of diplomats who will stay at the
kabul airport for now by the way how bad
was this this is so bad and so rushed
and such a botched job that the united
states left behind billions of dollars
in equipment for the afghan taliban to
simply take over according to the agence
france press the united states spent
billions supplying the afghan military
with the tools to defeat the taliban the
rapid capitulation of the armed forces
means that that weaponry is now fueling
the insurance astonishing at battlefield
successes
president joe biden said we provided our
afghan partners with all the tools let
me emphasize all the tools but the
taliban have just been seizing all of
weapons caches they've they've picked up
humvees they've picked up
apache attack helicopters
in the western city of pharaoh fighters
are patrolling in a car marked with an
eagle swooping on a snake which is the
official insignia of the country's
intelligence services
the taliban blitz his hands are the
group vehicles humvees small arms and
light weapons weapons as well as
ammunition
according to the
weapons tracking group conflict armament
research
experts say that such halls have given
the taliban a massive boost
the weapons will not only help the
taliban march on kabul but strengthen
its authority in the cities it has
already captured
so they just ended up with a bunch of
your taxpayer dollars in their hands in
the form of actual weaponry
according to the new york times taliban
fighters poured into the afghan capital
on sunday amid scenes of panic and chaos
bringing a swift and shocking close to
the afghan government and the 20-year
american era in the country president
ash afghani of afghanistan fled the
country a council of afghan officials
including former president hamid karzai
said they would open negotiations with
the taliban over the shape of the
insurgency's takeover by day's end the
insurgents had all but officially sealed
their control of the entire country
hastily arranged american military
helicopter flights evacuating the
sprawling american embassy compound in
kabul ferrying american diplomats and
afghan embassy workers to the kabul
military airport at the civilian airport
next door afghans wept as they begged
airline workers to put their families on
outbound commercial flights even as most
were grounded in favor of military
aircraft there were apparently reports
as well that some of the airlines the
civilian airliners wouldn't let people
aboard because they didn't have a
coveted dust
so they're just going to stay behind and
get slaughtered the enemy coveted dust
really solid stuff all the way around
for the west a bunch of eighth century
barbarians who are now taking over
sophisticated military equipment from
western powers they just took over
auspices of the 700 million dollar
american embassy in kabul
sovereign american territory that was
just taken over by the taliban
and of course
the people who were let out were let out
largely by fools in the west and by the
way this is a bipartisan problem barack
obama and georgia so georgia let's start
from the beginning george w bush
misdefined the mission in afghanistan
the mission in afghanistan was very
clearly to get rid of al qaeda and get
rid of the taliban to prevent them from
taking over again and letting al qaeda
back in
okay the the mission was not it was a
side mission it was nice the mission was
not human rights the mission was not
establishment of a long-term democracy
the mission was preventing this from
being a terror base period end of story
if that had been made clear over and
over and over again perhaps the american
people would have been willing to make
the what amounts to at this point a
relatively minute sacrifice to maintain
a small troop presence in afghanistan at
the time the united states left there
were 3 500 troops on the ground in
afghanistan largely to control for
example bagram air base which is now
controlled by the taliban
okay those 3 500 combat troops
represented a tiny minute proportion of
american military power all over the
world the last american soldier who had
died in combat was killed february 8
2020 it has been a year and a half the
united states is spending on average
about 40 45 billion dollars a year on
afghanistan which amounts to
approximately one percent of the federal
budget before covid
now with the new budgets it's going to
amount to half a percentage point of our
federal budget
this was not a quote unquote endless war
that required the united states to pull
out fourth with leaving people to be
slaughtered in the streets and the
taliban to rush back in to take back
over the entire country with no
possibility by the way of america now
being able to stage attacks on actual
terrorist positions because we don't
have air bases there anymore
we
okay so george w bush missed defined the
mission fair then barack obama runs on
the platform of pulling out in 2008 and
then as president he realizes that this
is actually not such a great idea and so
he sort of takes a halfway position
instead of actually securing our
position in afghanistan he starts
doing like a mid-range surge and then he
starts making back door overtures to the
taliban that continues under president
trump who also campaigned on ending the
war in afghanistan and was making pretty
open overtures to the taliban i mean
there was american negotiation going on
with the taliban in qatar
and then that was followed by joe biden
who decided to finish this thing by
simply pulling out with no negotiations
with no possibility of real
of real commitment with nothing
for no reason at all
none
okay and the net result is going to be
that look the american people apparently
are willing to go to war but we are not
willing at this point to see these
things through even if it means a minor
and it is in the scheme of how america's
spending goes in the scheme of america's
military commitment a minor commitment
to baseline security in places like
afghanistan and by the way that gap will
be filled by somebody
now what's what's funny about this is
that was joe biden's calculation all
along joe biden's calculation was if i
pull out there will be some sort of
political boon for me i don't think that
boon is coming i think the american
people are going to be reawakened to the
threats that the taliban represent and
that al qaeda represents and that
terrorist states in the middle east
represent when there is no militating
backlash by the united states and or its
allies
in the meantime however the united
states made a bunch of crucial errors
for example
emptying out gitmo under barack obama
negotiating with the taliban okay here
is a taliban fighter literally saying oh
yeah by the way i was in gitmo for eight
years the united states released
a bunch of the leaders who are currently
in charge of the taliban were released
at the behest of the united states
i was in guantanamo for eight years
by the way not just this guy okay
according to the guardian abdul ghani
bharadar who's the taliban leader he was
freed from the pakistani jail at the
request of the united states less than
three years ago
he has now merged as an undisputed
victor of the 20-year war
baradar is the political chief in the
most public phase he was said to be on
his way from his office in doha to kabul
on sunday evening and televised
statement on the fall of kabul he said
the taliban's real test was only just
beginning they had to serve the nation
by presumably stuffing women back into
bags and or into basements making sure
none of them ever read again and
ensuring that women don't walk publicly
without a male next to them like this is
operating in the in the 8th century
seems to be a way of running the nation
baradar played a succession of military
and administrative roles in the
five-year taliban regime by the time it
was ousted he was deputy minister of
defense during the taliban's 20-year
exile baradar had the reputation of
being a potent military leader and a
subtle political operator western
diplomats came to view him as on the
wing of the katashira the talibans
regrouped leadership in exile that was
most resistant to isi control that's the
pakistani intelligence service and most
amenable to political contact with kabul
the obama administration was more
fearful of his military expertise than
hopeful about his supposedly moderate
leanings the cia tracked him down in
karachi in 2010 and then persuaded the
isi which is the pakistani secret
service to arrest him
in 2018 washington's attitude changed
donald trump's afghan envoy zame
khalilzad asked the pakistanis to
release bharadar so he could lead
negotiations in qatar because everybody
on both sides of the al decided that
this was not a war worth a minimum of
effort at this point at all now i think
all of that is wrong but even if you
think all of that is right what is
certainly wrong is the
insane way that joe biden just decided
to pull out of this thing
even if you think it's good policy for
the united states not to be involved in
afghanistan
the way that joe biden has performed
this is the crappiest way anyone could
have ever performed this
it truly is an astonishing failure by
joe biden
who also is saying that he's not going
to do any pressers he's not doing no
need does he have to talk to you nah
matlock is on
he's too busy he's got things going on
we'll get to joe biden's reaction in
just one moment first let us talk about
keeping your home safe there are a
thousand reasons why protecting your
home it matters to you and there are a
lot of reasons why protecting my home it
matters to me if somebody stops by or
something is going on outdoors around
the house ring will let me know it is
peace of mind anytime knowing our home
is protected
you can protect your home with ring
alarm ring alarm is a powerful
affordable whole home security system
you can easily install yourself it works
seamlessly with other ring products in
one simple app for a special offer go to
ringgit.com it is the perfect way to
start your ring experience keep an eye
on every corner of your house with
indoor and outdoor cams see what's
happening right from your phone
and ring alarm is super easy to install
like really you can do it yourself as
soon as we move from california to
florida my wife's first priority making
sure that the ring devices were on the
house and now i can keep track of my
kids no matter where i am protect your
home anytime from anywhere with ring
alarm go to ring.com for a special offer
on a ring alarm security kit today you
can build a system right for your home
have it up and running in just minutes
that's ring.com
once more ring.com
again that is
ring.com for a special offer on a ring
alarm security kit today okay so
things are getting incredibly ugly over
there obviously cnn reporter cliff
clarissa ward she says people here are
absolutely terrified
we can certainly hear quite a lot of
gunfire going on over the course of the
last hour or two particularly i should
say again very difficult to know what
exactly that gun fire is because you do
hear a lot of it in kabul but certainly
fair to say there's a lot more of it
tonight than we're used to hearing and
certainly also fair to say that people
here in the capital are utterly
petrified and essentially have nowhere
to look to now
that of course isn't no shock at all
people are attempting to flee and the
videos are just horrifying
if this was not supposed to be like
saigon i just have a question how maybe
it's not like saigon maybe it's just
world war z because these videos look
like world war z it looks like the
zombie invasion is coming and people are
attempting to get on planes they're
they're they're climbing up
the the on-ramps on the planes and
they're just flooding them there's no
organization whatsoever it's insanity
here's some of the videos
this is those are civilian airliners in
the background people flooding onto the
tarmac desperately attempting to get out
people showing up with their families
trying to leave before the taliban come
in and kill everybody who is perceived
as a collaborator
that was just some of the video
the the
evacuations underway at kabul airport
are shocking some of the video shows
people it's a lot closer up you can see
people actually climbing up the stairs
and they're just falling off the
railings i mean it's it's utter insanity
and afghans are of course being stranded
by the thousands by the thousands by the
hundreds of thousands at this point
none of this should be any sort of shock
at all because it isn't according to the
wall street journal
rahmat said he was relieved when the
central intelligence agency phoned him
for an interview and weeks later
arranged to shelter him on an afghan
base while the state department
processed his application for a visa to
flee afghanistan he feared the taliban
were hunting him down for his work
spying for the cia in a remote in a
remote border area of afghanistan for
almost a decade and lack the paperwork
to apply for a visa but rahmat isn't in
the clear the taliban are advancing on
kabul even if he can make it to the
capital from his hideout in a province
hours away the afghan commander of the
base has since told him he can't shelter
there
i'm very worried he said in a text
message we are feeling in danger here
please save our family rahmat's story
reflects the fears of thousands of
afghans who helped the us during the war
and now face a desperate race to leave
the country the wall street journal
agreed to only use his first name to
protect his safety as best they can
about 18 000 families
who have applied for the us's special
immigrant visa remain on the ground in
afghanistan
okay this is
as of
two days ago
okay thousand eighteen thousand families
remaining on the ground in afghanistan
no way to get out
half of those are outside kabul you know
areas either already under taliban
control or likely to fall soon which now
is everything because it's all fallen
in addition the state department this
month said tens of thousands more
afghans would be eligible for priority
treatment under u.s refugee settlement
program the new criteria applied to
afghans who work for u.s contractors u.s
funded programs and us-based media or
non-governmental organizations as well
as their families
but how the hell are you going to get
them out the answer is now you're not
you're not because you had no orderly
transition process the entire place has
been taken over by the barbarians from
the 8th century no one is getting out
former soldiers aid workers others who
previously worked in afghanistan have
been inundated with requests from former
afghan colleagues and employees seeking
letters of recommendation and help in
fleeing the country
this is just
obviously horrifying stuff it's going to
get more horrifying by the way the
footage will eventually emerge of people
simply being shot because the taliban is
apparently doing this the taliban is
simply taking places over and murdering
people
the new york times reporting on what
it's like living under the taliban as
they rush into kunduz it was his first
day as the taliban appointed mayor of
kunduz and gul muhammad elias was on a
charm offensive last sunday the
insurgents seized control of the city in
northern afghanistan which was in
shambles after weeks of fighting power
lines were down the water supplied
powered by generators did not reach most
residents trash and rubble littered the
streets the civil servants could fix
those problems were hiding at home
terrified of the taliban so this so the
insurgent commander turned mayor
summoned some to his new office to
persuade them to return to work i said
our jihad is not with the municipality
our jihadis against the occupiers and
those who defend the occupiers but day
by day his municipal offices stayed
mostly empty mr elias grew more
frustrated and his rhetoric grew harsher
taliban fighters began going
door-to-door searching for absentee city
workers hundreds of armed men set up
checkpoints across the city at the
entrance to the regional hospital a new
notice appeared on the wall employees
must return to work or face punishment
from the taliban just a week after the
fall of kunduz the insurgents are now in
effect of control of afghanistan now
they must function as administrators who
can provide basic services to hundreds
of thousands of
people in just days the insurgents
frustrated by their failed efforts to
control civil servants back to work
began instilling terror according to
residents reached by telephone i'm
afraid i don't know what'll happen and
what they will do said one we have to
smile at them because we are scared but
we are deeply unhappy three days after
the taliban took control in kunduz a
takula omar kiel a civil servant
received a call from an insurgent
fighter telling him to go to his office
the mayor of kunduz wanted to speak with
him mr omar kiel had been staying home
since the retreat of government forces
as insurgents flooded into the streets
and a sense of unease gripped the
battered city he had experienced a
similar moment twice before when the
taliban seized kunduz in 2015 and 2016.
both times the insurgents were pushed
back with help from the american
airstrikes this time days after the
taliban took control the entire afghan
army corps charged with reclaiming the
city surrendered to the insurgents they
gave them their weapons and they gave
them their vehicles all of the
government's vehicles garbage trucks and
computers were exactly where he had left
them before the taliban took over and
young fighters poured into the city the
only sign of change was blank spaces on
the walls where photos of president
ashraf ghani had been instead the
taliban's white flags had been hung
mr alas assured the workers they would
not be targeted by the taliban and
instructed them to return to work to
improve but morale
halfway through the meeting a shopkeeper
pleaded with the taliban bodyguard see
the mayor like hundreds of others his
kiosk had been mostly destroyed by fire
during the taliban's final push he said
shopkeepers one of the talibans promised
they could return to the market to
collect their things safe safely the
mayor complied for the rest of the day
elias met with other municipal leaders
trying to get services restored there is
some progress but nearly every shop is
closed the shopkeepers are fearing that
they will be looted by the taliban
fighters
about 500 taliban fighters were
stationed around the city manning
checkpoints on nearly every street
corner
by the end of the week many residents
fears were being realized at the
regional hospitals taliban fighters
seized a list of employees phone numbers
and home addresses began calling them
demanding they returned to work
one person who had fled to kabul
received a call from a taliban fighter
demanding he returned to work
at the hospital armed taliban were
keeping track of attendance female staff
were sky blue burkas as they assisted in
surgeries and tended to wounds from the
air strikes
just things are going to go great things
are going to go just beautifully okay so
it's not just that there are terrible
ramifications for everybody who is stuck
in afghanistan of course is that there
are bad ramifications for the united
states
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff mark milley when he's not
lecturing everybody about the
evils of of white privilege he told
senators on sunday a previous assessment
of how soon terrorist groups will
reconstitute in afghanistan will speed
up
on a sunday phone call between top biden
officials and senators from both parties
senator lindsey graham asked defense
secretary lloyd austin and millie
whether they will revise an assessment
to congress in june of a medium risk of
terrorist groups reconstituting in
afghanistan within two years melee said
yes he would have to assume that
timeline would now be roomed up he would
be happy to brief senators in the
classified setting
sources on the call described a surreal
experience listening in on the biden
officials briefed them on the situation
while checking their cell phones and
seeing real-time chaos unfolding in
kabul
senators from both parties pressed
millie and austin on efforts to evacuate
us personnel and the many thousands of
afghans who helped americans in the war
effort and are desperately trying to
escape a source said the sad reality is
there's no way they can evacuate by
august 31st the more than 20 000 afghans
want to escape the country and that's
not including their families you're
probably talking more like 75 or 80 000
people who want to escape the country
and are not going to be able to get out
two takeaways for me one said one source
we're gonna leave tens of thousands of
people behind and a timeline in terms of
threats has now accelerated remember
that was the original reason we went
there in the first place
anthony blinken was asked is the taliban
controlled territory now going to become
a hotbed of terrorism again he just
avoided the question as he is apt to do
you don't think that afghanistan now is
going to become a hotbed of terrorism
jake we have uh tremendously more
capacity than we had before 911 when it
comes to counter terrorism in places
around the world where we don't have
forces on the ground in yemen uh in
parts of uh of africa in parts of syria
we're able to deal with any potential
terrorist threat uh to our country and
we're doing that every single day and
look uh i can't tell you what uh what
the taliban is going to do
um that would be a complete non-answer
so he asked him is afghanistan going to
become a terre haute he's like well
yemen isn't
say well i noticed that yemen isn't in
afghanistan so that's a weird answer
anthony blinken by the way when the
united states leaves a vacuum somebody
rushes in to fill it according to
foreign policy magazine it is not merely
a question of what happens in
afghanistan it's also a question of the
united states global enemies
maximizing their benefit right now
according to foreign policy.com u.s
presidential biden's announcement u.s
troops will be gone from afghanistan by
august 31st will remove the most
formidable obstacle to total taliban
takeover of the country
for 20 years the u.s presence in
afghanistan though not always
appreciated has nevertheless served as a
predictable and stabilizing force now
the prospect of a new taliban rule has
sparked major anxiety among the region's
powers for example earlier this month
indian minister of external affairs s
jaishankar visited moscow and tehran
while taliban representatives were in
each city raising questions about
whether back channel negotiations are
ongoing so india doesn't want to be on
the outside looking in because
afghanistan which will ally presumably
with pakistan now provides a threat to
india so india is going to start making
overtures to afghanistan
meanwhile china is going to be making
overtures to afghanistan as well russia
is making overtures to the taliban
moscow is preparing to leverage the six
nation collective security treaty
organization to address potential
trouble at the afghan tajik border which
is being taken over by the taliban on
the afghan side
islamabad has now negotiated that that's
pakistan a quid pro quo with the taliban
to reject u.s bases on pakistani
territory in exchange for the taliban's
assistance in combating pakistan's own
taliban-style militants so now it's not
even that the united states is going to
lose its bases in afghanistan also the
u.s is going to have no staging bases in
pakistan
okay which is next door so there went
the security cooperation with pakistan
whatever that was worth
amid all of this regional angst china is
quietly attempting to secure its
interests in post at us afghanistan
beijing has been actively engaging with
kabul on construction of a peshwa kabul
motorway which will connect pakistan to
afghanistan and make kabul a participant
in china's belt and road initiative up
until now kabul didn't want to do that
because the united states was helping
them out now beijing is building a major
road through the wakan corridor a slim
strip of mountainous territory
connecting china's western most promised
province of zhanjiang to afghanistan and
onward to pakistan and central asia
according to a 2014 report and
afghanistan may possess nearly a
trillion dollars worth of extractable
rare earth metals locked within his
mountains
china will now have some control over
that
yes when the united states leaves a
vacuum bad things happen okay so
time to ask a serious question how did
any of this happen how did this happen
in the first place i gave you a sort of
brief history of afghanistan and the
failures of all the administrations
prior
but let's talk for just one second about
joe biden so
joe biden is now blaming trump he of
course says well it's not my fault that
i decided to simply precipitously
withdraw they put out a pathetic picture
like over the weekend
this white house tweet they tweeted out
a picture of joe biden alone in the
situation room
saying this morning the president and
vice president met with their national
security team and senior officials to
hear updates on the drawdown of our
civilian personnel in afghanistan
evacuations of siv applicants and other
afghan allies and the ongoing security
situation in kabul well i mean if you
took a picture
i mean as long as we know that's not a
stock photo or anything there was
speculation that was a stock photo by
the way we don't know if that's true or
not the speculation was because on the
wall the time difference between moscow
and china is apparently two hours when
it should be three
and the reason that is two hours is
because before march is actually a
two-hour time difference so people are
speculating that's not actually a photo
from like right now it doesn't really
matter very much bottom line is joe
biden is not present
okay according to the wall street
journal during the 2020 political
campaign biden presented himself as a
globe-trotting leader who at home the
senate foreign relations committee
served as barack obama's point man on a
complex international issues and who is
determined to bring a steady hand to
national security
yet the turmoil that is now engulfed in
afghanistan which has led biden to send
5000 troops back to the country by the
way which by the way that's double the
number of troops that he was taking out
in april so remember that time we were
supposed to withdraw now we have 6 000
troops total into the country apparently
has confronted the white house with a
rather large crisis
biden said in a statement on saturday
one more year or five more years of u.s
military presence would not would not
have made a difference if the afghan
military cannot or will not hold its own
country and an endless american presence
in the middle of another country's civil
conflict was not acceptable to me
well wait a second what i'm questioning
it wasn't about us being present in the
middle of another country civil conflict
it was do we have the capacity to back
allies in killing terrorists or not
that we do all over the world by the way
the united states military is present in
over 100 countries
this apparently will not be one of them
even though it is now a chief terror
target
meanwhile by the way lincoln ramped up
the biden administration's effort to
deflect criticism saying that trump had
allowed the taliban threat to grow okay
so here's the question even assuming
that's true even assuming that trump
blew it with regard to the taliban you
came in and then just handed them the
country along with all of our allies who
will now be slaughtered along with all
of our resources because you decided to
precipitously pull out announce the date
and then just leave
and by the way it's even worse than that
joe biden wants to take a credit for
that he overruled everybody to do this
his own intelligence officials were
saying this is an idiotic idea his own
generals were saying this is moronic
i mean president biden said on saturday
he's going to be sending approximately 5
000 u.s troops to safely evacuate us and
allied personnel according to the wall
street journal a force slightly larger
than the 3 000 personnel who are already
in transit back to afghanistan and the
1000 already there but this spectacular
failure stemmed from built-in flaws of
the afghan military compounded by
strategic blundering of the government
of afghan president ashkev ghani
the taliban took advantage of u.s
sponsored peace talks to deceive kabul
about their intentions as they prepared
and executed a lightning offensive
here is that here's the key part you
ready here's how bad biden blew this
the afghan army fighting alongside
american troops was molded to match the
way the americans operate
the us military the world's most
advanced relies heavily on combining
ground operations with air power using
aircraft to resupply outposts strike
targets ferry the wounded and collect
reconnaissance and intelligence
in the wake of president biden's
withdrawal decision the us pulled its
air support intelligence and contractors
servicing afghanistan's planes and
helicopters that meant the afghan
military simply could not operate
anymore the same happened with another
failed american effort the south
vietnamese army in the 1970s said
retired lieutenant general daniel bolger
who commanded the us-led coalition's
mission to train afghan forces in 2011
and 2013. so just to reiterate the
united states worked with the afghan
forces they trained them in a certain
type of combat namely they could call
american airstrikes in they had the
ability to call in american air
resources to clear an area or to pick up
the wounded and then what did joe biden
do he said we're not doing any of that
anymore so it's not just a matter of air
support disappearing it's a matter of
the entire model was rooted in a
particular level of american support and
without any warning whatsoever biden
just went through the support boom all
the supports are gone
okay that is like a house that exists in
the hollywood hills and the foundations
are not particularly stable
you could shore up those foundations or
theoretically you could just dynamite
them and then be surprised when the
house falls down joe biden decided to
dynamite the foundations for whatever
the security strategy was here
there's always a tendency to use the
model you know which is your own model
so general bulger who now teaches
history at north carolina state
university when you build an army like
that and it's meant to be a partner with
a sophisticated force like the americans
you can't pull the americans out all of
a sudden because then they lose the
day-to-day assistance they need
when u.s forces were still operating
here the afghan government sought to
maximize its presence through the
country's far-flung countryside
maintaining more than 200 bases in
outposts that could resupplied be
resupplied only by air there were no
resupplies available once the united
states removed its support extending
government operations to the more the
most of america of afghanistan's more
than 400 districts has long been the
main pillar of america's
counterinsurgency strategy
mr ghani had ample warning of the
american departure after the trump
administration signed a february 2020
agreement with the taliban calling on
u.s u.s forces and contractors to leave
by may 2021 but
the afghan government failed to adjust
its military footprint to match the new
reality many officials didn't believe
that they would actually leave
okay by the way joe biden was informed
of all of this he was told about all of
this and then he just did it anyway
that's the part that's so so stunning
i mean
he he overruled his own advisors
there were none of his advisors told him
that this was a good idea they were all
telling him it's a terrible idea
they were telling him exactly what was
going to happen this wasn't an
intelligence failure as people people
are trying to blame this on the intel
community this is not intelligence
failure this is a political fail whereby
joe biden he did not care what happened
next period
that's the end of it
i mean how bad was this by the way how
bad did joe biden
absolutely f these people
how bad he did it it's so bad that
president biden refuses to allow
contractors to continue operating in the
country
there's no support he withdrew all of it
they are all gone
according to the daily beast in the last
few weeks afghanistan's air force became
a sticking point negotiations between
the biden administration and afghan
officials according to one person
familiar with the talks the country's
mostly u.s provided air fleet was
dependent on foreign contractors to
assist with maintenance
as the us withdrawal took hold the biden
administration refused to even allow
contractors into the country to service
the afghan military's aircraft
the united states effectively grounded
the afghan air force
so we took away our planes and we said
you can't use those anymore and the
afghan government said okay fine we'll
use ours can we at least borrow some of
your contractors so you know our
airplanes fly and this is like nope
you're on your own you're gonna have to
get muhammad over there the guy who's
hurting the sheep you're gonna have to
get him over here he's gonna have to fix
up the apache
and then they're surprised at what
happened
in the interim afghan air air crews were
forced to get creative maintenance
personnel were relying on zoom calls
with american experts in order to figure
out how to maintain the aircraft left
behind by the americans i'm sure that
was going great i'm sure customers are
okay can you get a better angle you got
your zoom ready okay we're gonna take
out your laptop you're gonna aim it in
the general direction of the engine of
an apache attack helicopter and now i
need you to explain to me why it's not
working
gonna go fantastic
now is a mood issue photos posted to
social media show the taliban fighters
have captured us provided a 29 super
tecano light air attack aircraft and
md530f helicopters
former british international development
secretary rory stewart told the bbc on
sunday everything is going wrong schools
are shutting down across the country
clinics are shutting down across the
country people are taking refuge in
their home looting is taking place
and of course
again everybody who
had the temerity to work with us is
going to be murdered that's that is the
likely next step here
now the good news is
that again the state department is
making some very strong statements here
like some very very strong statements in
fact the state department put out this
particular statement and is a stunning
masterpiece of just self-importance and
delusion quote given these deteriorating
security situation we support are
working to secure and call on all
parties to respect and facilitate the
safe and orderly departure of foreign
nationals and afghans who wish to leave
the country those in positions of power
and authority across afghanistan bear
responsibility and accountability for
the protection of human life and
property and for the immediate
restoration of security and civil order
afghans and international citizens who
wish to depart must be allowed to do so
roads airports and border crossings must
remain open and calm must be maintained
the afghan people deserve to live in
safety security and dignity we in the
international community stand ready to
assist them
stand ready to assist them you literally
just left you literally just left
okay this is a domestic argument where
the police officer arrives and the
husband is literally beating the wife to
death and the police officer takes one
look and goes you know what can't do
anything here and walks away but as he
walks away says lady if you need help
remember i'm only a 911 phone call away
that's what this is right now
that is so unbelievably delusional
so unbelievably delusional but by the
way the delusions don't stop there
we'll get to more delusional nonsense
from the states about this is crazy i
mean it's absolutely not don't worry
though joe biden is not going to miss an
episode of matlock he has not spoken to
the american people over the weekend at
all
he wasn't planning to the taliban had a
press conference from the from the
headquarters of the afghan government
but joe biden that dude's playing
shuffleboard up at camp david he cannot
be bothered
we'll get to maura in just one second i
mean this like you know how many
americans died to secure at least a base
a foothold for the united states to
target terror in this region
you know how many americans were wounded
in afghanistan tens of thousands of
americans
lost limbs were wounded suffer severe
psychological distress in order to
maintain a base of operations from which
we can kill terrorists we don't get
another 911. and this dumbass decides
you know what i'm pulling out i'm not
providing any support i'm going to not
even allow contractors in there to fix
their airplanes
but how did this happen and by the way
it's nothing like saigon i mean just
nothing how could you even see a
similarity between this in saigon
unreal we'll get some more in just one
second first
let's be real about this when you are
thinking about sleep quality you tend to
think about your mattress which is great
you tend to think about a lot of things
in your room one thing you probably
don't think too much about your sheets
you need an excellent set of sheets
experience uncompromising comfort with
the best-selling 100 organic cotton
signature hem sheets from bowl and
branch bowling branch to make the
world's best sheets the cloud weight
supersoft sateen weave gets softer with
every single wash it's crafted to the
highest standards and attention to
detail from sourcing to packaging it's
the perfect balance of weight and
breathability to pamper warm or cool
sleepers through any season
give your bed the white house treatment
with sheets that three presidents have
fallen in love with well in branches
dedicated to quality at every single
step sheets designed and manufactured
for maximum comfort and durability no
cutting quarters there are no middlemen
between you and bowling branch you get
luxury quality for the fairest price
honestly like the only sheets that i now
own and use regularly are bullet and
branch sheets they're just that good
go check them out right now to
experience an entirely new standard of
comfort visit bull and branch dot com
get 15 off your first set of sheets with
promo code shapiro that's b-o-l-l and
branch dot com promo code shapiro go
check them out right now and we'll get
some more in just one second on this
very dark day in american history first
if you've been searching for a daily
morning podcast without an agenda look
no further than the morning wire it's
been topping the apple and spotify
charts since its recent release it is
the only daily news podcast that values
your time and the truth and while we are
working overtime to bring you the news
you need to know we need your help to
keep the facts trending toward number
one so subscribe and start listening
right now to morning wire on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts leave a five star review if you
like what you hear other news if you've
been wondering what it's like to sit
front row at candace's new show candace
you might just be in luck if you sign up
now as a daily wire member with code vip
you get 25 off your memberships right
there that is a great deal but also
you're out automatically entered for a
chance to win a trip for two you and a
guest to the daily wear studios to see
candace live not only will you meet
candace you'll get an inside look at her
studio and front row seats to watch her
take down leftists live and at action on
her talk show candace so get a great
deal on a new dailywear membership at
dailywire.com
subscribe with code vip and 25 off so
you can automatically be entered for a
chance to win that vip experience hurry
this deal is going away after wednesday
act fast get your membership discount
and a chance to win that is
dailywire.com subscribe get 25 off with
code vip you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so the state department's
response to this divine administration's
response to this is so unbelievably
insane i mean it's truly crazy it really
is
and it is as though
o.j simpson just murdered a bunch of
people it's at least some guy who's just
standing there watching o.j simpson do
it
it's like don't worry guys i can always
if you need me to step in i'm right here
meanwhile i'm just sitting there having
a pina colada watching oj kill his
ex-wife like th this is pretty much what
is happening right now with the united
states
the state department statement where
they said that they stand ready to
assist in any way is just so crazy
nancy pelosi loved it by the way nancy
pelosi actually put out her own
statement she said the president is to
be commended for the clarity of purpose
of his statement on afghanistan and his
action the taliban must know the world
is watching its actions we are concerned
about reports regarding the taliban's
brutal treatment of all afghans
especially women and girls
oh really
oh really are you concerned quote the us
the international community and the
afghan government must do everything we
can to protect women and girls from
inhumane treatment by the taliban as we
strive to assist them we must recognize
that their voices are important and
respect their culture
is she
is she addled i mean the answer is
clearly yes she's an adult i mean there
is a screw loose
all the lights are not on upstairs there
are marbles missing from the marble jar
that pinball machine broke long ago
i'm running out of euphemisms for how
crazy that statement is
that is so crazy
i mean what so we care deeply about the
afghan women and girls and the afghan
government bears serious responsibility
and i nancy pelosi will tut-tet
tut the 8th century cavemen about their
treatment of women and girls that's how
much we care
we care so much the international
community will hold you responsible by
completely leaving and letting those
girls get hit with acid in the face for
going to school but nancy pelosi cares
so deeply about women she's so much for
women's rights that she tweets angrily
about things that don't even make any
sense
my good she
she is a couple of cards shy of a full
deck that that lady wow wow
okay tony blinken for his for his part
the state department secretary he says
you know it's not in our interest to
stay after all
like it or not uh there was an agreement
that the forces would come out on may
1st had they not had we not begun that
process which is what the president did
and the taliban saw then we would have
been back at war with the taliban by the
way from the perspective of our
strategic competitors around the world
there's nothing they would like more
than to see us in afghanistan for
another 5 10 20 years it's simply not in
the national interest that's insane
they would they would like to see us
stay there then why is it that the
minute we left the russians and the
chinese all rushed in
and the pakistanis and the indians and
everybody else why why we all know the
answer to this
not in our interest to stay but our
strategic competitors are happy if we
stay
in what world in what insane world this
is so disconnected from anything
remotely resembling reality
this is what's maddening what happened
here is that a perfectly pure and
beautiful idea ran up directly against
the brick wall of reality and the brick
wall of reality is winning it is not a
shock the biden administration decided
to drive thelma and louise style this
car directly over the cliff and it was
fun until gravity applied
right the movie it turns out didn't end
with the car in slo-mo sailing over a
gap it turns out the movie continues and
then the car bursts into flame when it
hits the bottom with the two ladies
inside that's the part they don't show
in the movie because it's not heroic
when you burst into flame at the bottom
and you die it means you're a
okay and what they've done here is
moronic on every pot and it is and it is
not only intellectually moronic it is it
is it is politically moronic it is in
terms of foreign policy immoral
but tony blinken i love these kind of
statements he then says you know what
but here's the thing we will not
legitimize our government if they don't
do what we want them to do we won't give
them legitimacy you literally handed
them the country we won't legitimize
that government well
if you don't invite them to your
georgetown cocktail party i'm sure the
taliban are gonna be super pissed
if they can't get a nice manhattan
they'll probably just
cry themselves to sleep
with their ak-47s and the apache attack
helicopters you just gave them
probably they will weep into their beer
over not being able to eat caviar with
anthony blinken here's bling and say
we're not gonna legitimize their
government we wouldn't do that we're not
no they are illegitimate
you sir you sir are illegitimate what in
the world
illegitimate
the guys like
again i go back to the oj thing it's
like oh just like stabbing his ex-wife
and the guys are like sir
you seem unpleasant to me
what you're doing is quite illegitimate
and i insist that you stop
yes this is this is working out well
here's anthony blanken a future afghan
government that
upholds the basic rights
of its people uh and that doesn't harbor
terrorists uh is a government we can
work with and uh and recognize
conversely
a government that doesn't do that that
doesn't uphold the basic rights of its
people including women and girls uh that
uh that uh harbors uh terrorist groups
that have designs on the united states
or allies and partners certainly that's
not going to happen oh man we won't be
happy with you we won't be by the way
the agreement that you insisted on
keeping also had requirements of the
taliban like don't invade the entire
country
you know what they didn't do listen to
any of that and then you say that you're
abiding by those agreements
whatever agreement trump made was also
contingent on taliban performance of
their end
you didn't care you said you didn't care
you said if they violate the agreement
you wouldn't do anything and you didn't
by the way here's the good news
president biden is expected to address
the nation according to cnn not like
there's anything going on in the world
hey he's busy he's a busy guy he's at
camp david cutting his toenails and
making sure that that he eats his cream
of wheat in the proper measure
he
the man needs his cannabin sure every
morning he doesn't have time for you and
your petty worries about you know the
destruction of an entire nation because
we failed to keep any sort of basic
level of moral or foreign policy
commitment
he's a busy busy man
that's all
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with much much more in the meantime go
check out the michael knowles show that
is available right now i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
as the taliban takes over afghanistan
the department of homeland security
insists that the real terrorists are
american conservatives check it out on
the michael knowles show